this is in wennington in greater london
residential uh area ablaze there london
fire brigades say they have 15 engines
and a hundred firefighters tackling this
blaze which is on the green in
wennington uh greater london the mayor
of london sadiq khan says
the london fire brigade has just
declared a major incident in response to
a huge surge in fires across the capital
today this is critical the london fire
brigade is under immense pressure please
be safe i'm in touch with the
commissioner and we'll share updates
when i have them um london fire gate
simultaneously fighting this uh fire in
wennington greater london and also
another blaze in croydon today there are
around two dozen fires up and down
the uk yesterday there's also been
another fire in upminster in essex today
as well tinderbox conditions caused by
temperatures exceeding 40 degrees
celsius that unwanted record uk record
broken at heathrow earlier on today it
remains at 40.2 degrees celsius could
creep up though towards the end of today
we were keeping an eye
on the official forecast for you but
this the scene in weddington as i said
london fire brigade declaring a major
incident in response to what is
happening across london uh the mayor of
london saying don't have barbecues on
grass or on balconies don't leave broken
bottles or glass on the grass it can
start fires dispose of cigarettes safely
and report a fire as soon as you see one
do not take risks stay safe in the heat
what you're watching here is the
consequences of not heeding that advice
in these record-breaking temperatures